cueillir à présent notre grand témoin
pour son 86e livre rendez-vous compte
Jacques Attali nous livre une nouvelle
histoire mondiale cette fois c'est celle
de l'éducation et comme à chaque fois il
se plonge dans le passé pour tirer des
leçons pour l'avenir alors comment notre
école accusé de tous les mots doit-elle
évoluer comment transmettre aussi dans
un monde de plus en plus complexe
comment s'adapter aux métiers de demain
Jacques Attali nous rejoint juste après
l'invitation d'Hélène ponctuel
si on vous invite Jacques Attali vous le
polytechnicien énarque passionné par
l'histoire de nos sociétés c'est pour
nous aider à savoir si l'on fait fausse
route dans notre éducation je crois que
c'est le rôle principal des enseignants
c'est de faire des la plupart il
réussisse c'est de faire que
l'enseignement soit un lieu de de
plaisir de découverte et visiblement vos
enseignants vous ont donné le plaisir
des mots économiste aux fonctionnaires
chefs d'entreprise vous êtes aussi un
écrivain prolifique vous avez écrit plus
de 80 ouvrages et dans le dernier
histoire et avenir de l'éducation
voudrait c'est le panorama mondial de
notre système éducatif depuis 3000 ans
en réalité l'histoire des formes de
transmission du savoir et la France est
loin d'être exemplaire Didou et en
France on se situe au pire endroit en
termes de modèles parce qu'on a le pire
du système compétitif
et punitif parce que on note très jeune
on désigne les mauvais vous suggérer
dans votre livre de prendre exemple sur
les systèmes éducatifs de nos voisins de
robes du Nord notamment la Finlande pour
vous il faut également valoriser la
profession d'enseignants c'est une de
vos préconisations mais plus surprenant
comme s'instruirait socialement
indispensables vous émettez aussi l'idée
de récompenser toute personne qui
apprend vous êtes également partisan
d'une plus grande autonomie donnée aux
établissements une idée qui se rapproche
de l'école du futur lancée à Marseille à
la rentrée par Emmanuel Macron se dire
face à tous les défis qui sont les
nôtres et qui sont
très différent d'un territoire l'autre
comment on arrive à faire mieux
travailler toutes les parties prenantes
et au fond donner tout à la fois plus de
moyens mais plus de liberté aussi
pédagogique aux enseignants en lien avec
les parents d'élèves avec le
périscolaire avec les élus pour au fond
rétablir cette égalité des chances qui
est la promesse républicaine l'école
n'est qu'un des acteurs de la
transmission de la connaissance elle
doit cependant être repensée dites-vous
de manière hybride pour former à ces
métiers de demain ce qui n'existe pas
encore sur l'écologie la
cybercriminalité ou bien la
biotechnologie mais alors Jacques Attali
pour former à ses nouveaux métiers pour
une connaissance mieux partagée à quoi
doit ressembler notre salle de classe de
demain et d'ailleurs est-ce que ce sera
toujours une salle de classe
bonsoir Jacques Attali merci beaucoup
d'être fidèle à cette émission ben voilà
première question cette classe de demain
elle sera elle sera où elle sera dans
une école ou pas forcément dans quel
pays on parle dans la plupart des pays
du monde aujourd'hui il y a pas d'école
où il y a des écoles de très mauvaise
qualité avec un point pour santé élève
des élèves qui sont sur le sol et des
profs qui sont pas des pays d'Afrique je
parle l'essentiel de l'humanité en fait
et donc à peu près 60 à 70% ne sont pas
du niveau selon selon l'Unesco c'est
pareil en Inde c'est pareil pour large
partie de la Chine du large partie de
l'Amérique latine ou bien se dire ça
dans les pays les plus développés dans
dans 20 ans et dans
les pour les classes moyennes
supérieures
ou dans les pays qui ont réussi une
égalité remarquables comme la Finlande
qui est unique exceptionnel
l'école sera
avec 15 élèves par classe
avec l'accès à toutes les technologies
avec des professeurs qui seront aussi
bien payés que les meilleurs médecins
eux les meilleurs avocats avec des
programmes qui seront très librement
choisis par les profs dans un ensemble
de
projets avec une
enseignement collaboratif avec surtout
surtout et c'est ça qui va être très
nouveau à mon avis c'est ce qu'on a ce
que j'appelle les colibrins c'est-à-dire
qu'on fera classe une partie à l'école
vraiment comme comme le travail où on
est en partie en télétravail en partie
d'autant plus que ce que l'histoire
m'apprend et c'est pour ça que j'ai
quand j'écris des livres sur l'avenir
j'essaie de comprendre le passé
le passé montre que l'école ressemble
toujours à la façon de travailler dans
l'entreprise les ateliers c'était des
écoles un peu désordre l'école
d'aujourd'hui c'est le travail à la
chaîne les élèves qui passent d'une
classe à une autre comme les voitures
qui passent d'un poste de travail à un
autre et aujourd'hui on va vers un
travail hybride on est de temps en temps
chez soi de temps en temps ailleurs de
temps en temps sur le travail et ce sera
pareil alors j'ai une question parce
qu'on va revenir sur sur l'histoire
parce que c'est toujours très riche
d'enseignement pour pour penser l'avenir
qu'est-ce que l'éducation pour vous
qu'est-ce que vous mettez derrière ce
mot vous rendez hommage à de nombreux
professeurs qui ont été déterminants
pour vous d'ailleurs vous les citer
énormément en introduction vous dites ce
qui les réunissait c'est la passion de
transmettre est-ce que c'est ça
l'éducation d'abord j'ai appelé ce livre
Histoire et à venir de l'éducation au
pluriel mais j'aurais pu si le titre
n'aurait pas été trop ambigu les
appelait histoire et à venir de la
transmission parce que l'éducation au
sens de l'école n'est qu'une face
immergée ou émergée selon les cas de la
transmission qui se fait il s'est fait
très longtemps que par la famille pour
90% de l'humanité par le travail pour
les enfants qui allaient travailler à
partir de l'âge de 6 ans par les forains
jusqu'au milieu du 19e siècle d'ailleurs
la transmission des savoirs se fait plus
en dehors de l'école il y en a très peu
elles sont réservées
aux hommes de l'église
de toutes les églises c'est on forme les
gens d'église où on forme les gens au
savoir religieux ou quelques
serviteurs des pouvoirs l'école est un
moyen de pouvoir plus exactement l'école
est en train de réplication du système
social et ça change un peu partie du un
peu à partir de la réforme et un peu à
partir surtout à partir de du milieu du
19e siècle quand en particulier aux
États-Unis et dans quelques autres pays
il faut former tout le pays c'est très
intéressant d'ailleurs de voir à quel
point le clergé en Europe a tout fait
pour restreindre au maximum l'accès au
savoir les gens n'ont pas d'accès
évidemment à l'écriture lire et compter
c'est réservé à des à des élites il y a
une constante aussi c'est les femmes
dans l'histoire et ça quelle que soit
les modèles de civilisation et de
culture elles sont écartées
systématiquement de tous les Sabres
depuis l'antiquité la plus ancienne les
femmes sont écartées la moitié de
l'humanité n'a pas eu droit à savoir
est-ce que ça tient sans doute à ce que
les hommes
ont peur des femmes et comme l'école est
là pour maintenir le système en place il
faut pas que les déviants les marginaux
et les femmes sont de ce point de vue à
l'égard du système en place des
déviantes et des marginales faut pas que
ça accède fascinant j'ai retrouvé je
raconte très brièvement quelques
biographies de femmes qui ont réussi à
passer à travers les barrières il
fallait vraiment des qualités de
caractère de compétences extraordinaire
pour pour passer à travers et en effet
on a perdu pendant
10000 millénaires au moins alors les
compétences avant de parler de notre
système au combien critiquer très mal
classé dans le fameux pizza les
meilleurs les meilleurs modèles vous
avez deux modèles d'ailleurs très
différents la Finlande vous avez
commencé à nous en parler 15 ans élèves
par classe avec des professeurs très
bien payés et puis et puis la Corée du
Sud alors là c'est l'inverse énorme
pression pour des résultats extrêmement
brillants mais c'est ça il y a un
système ça renvoie aux deux idéologies
dominantes de notre temps qui sont
l'altruisme et l'individualisme
l'altruisme c'est travaillé ensemble
comprendre qu'on a intérêt à coopérer
faire des projets ensemble ne pas faire
de du classement de la hiérarchie une
valeur alors que le système Coraline Sud
qui est en fait l'héritage du système
chinois de 3000 ans
qui s'est poursuivi jusqu'au jusqu'à
aujourd'hui c'est les concours c'est
l'obsession de la sanction c'est la note
à partir de l'âge de 2 ans c'est
l'obsession qui conduit à des résultats
extraordinaires mais en même temps à des
suicides des inégalités parce qu'il faut
que les parents puissent payer des cours
complémentaires la sanction c'est
forcément une absurdité
si on peut l'éviter oui
l'évaluation
tous les systèmes d'éducation depuis
l'antiquité la plus ancienne de
transmission de l'Antiquité jusqu'à
aujourd'hui c'est répétitions sanction
récompense toujours été ça et il faut la
sanction c'est quand on a échoué alors
que si on crée des mécanismes
d'encouragement système finlandais de la
preuve il y a pas de sanction il y a pas
de notes encore une fois jusqu'à l'âge
du 14 ans alors parlons de notre modèle
au fond vous dites on cumule les
difficultés c'est le pire des systèmes
compétitifs et c'est le pire des
systèmes laxistes vous êtes très sévère
malheureusement les résultats de de
pizza c'est-à-dire de l'océde est une
des meilleures institutions
internationales des plus crédibles qui
donnent des statistiques très corrects
qui fait des études très approfondie
avec beaucoup d'objectivité et les
études de l'OCDE j'ai pu travailler avec
plusieurs de leurs experts montre que
non seulement nous sommes pas bons mais
nous sommes tomber dans tous les
domaines de que ça soit des universités
que ça soit de du niveau de scolaire des
enfants en mathématiques en lecture etc
mais aussi sont revenus ils ne sont plus
nous options mais c'était intéressant là
encore a d'abord pour que ça fasse effet
il faut du temps et ensuite c'est
vraiment terminale tandis que là il
s'agit du mathématiques en 6e et enfin
c'est encore plus mauvais si on regarde
simplement la question de la justice
sociale nous sommes des pays où il faut
le plus de temps un élève d'une certaine
classe sociale pour atteindre une autre
classe sociale et c'est d'ailleurs ça
qui donne un autre pays ce sentiment de
de recul c'est qu'un des parents ne
peuvent plus croire que leurs enfants
auront une meilleure vue que tout
simplement vu que parce que l'école le
leur garantit pas alors est-ce qu'on a
les moyens d'ordre le coup à tous
réalité là parce qu'il faut beaucoup
d'argent
il faut voilà une volonté politique
massive il faut une fille une
philosophie différente
nous on a construit une école depuis
l'école catholique du troisième siècle
de notre ère jusqu'à aujourd'hui sur
l'autorité on va vous enseigner ça vous
avez le droit de savoir que ça d'abord
que ça de religieux puis quand ça a
basculé dans la société que ça dans la
cité avec les batailles que je raconte
évidemment entre l'Église catholique et
les collègues mais toutes les deux avec
le même obsession non signé que ce qui
doit être enseigné donc il n'y a pas de
confiance dans le droit de faire autre
chose d'apprendre autrement de trouver
ce pourquoi on est bon de collaborer
avec les autres on transversale or quand
on fait confiance le grand risque c'est
une perte de contrôle nous sommes dans
une société la société française qui a
terriblement peur de perdre du contrôle
cette philosophie là à certains
enseignants l'ont déjà adapté sur le
terrain il y a ces enseignants à Drancy
je sais pas si vous connaissez ce cette
expérience absolument
ou les parents sont impliqués ou il y a
des règles
je parle de lui dans le livre il est son
expérience où les parents les enfants et
les enseignants collaborent mais non
seulement c'est une réussite et il y a
un documentaire qui est en train d'être
finalisé sur son travail et maintenant
il est en train de ces méthodes donc
finalement par le terrain par les
enseignants on peut changer plus les
choses que par la volonté politique
c'est très bien mais ça fait très
longtemps qu'il y a des expériences
magnifiques quand il y a au premier
siècle de notre ère je cite ces textes
ça devrait être on pourrait le dire
aujourd'hui comme les plus avancés
Pestalozzi au 18e siècle
Montessori au début du 20e siècle
freinait dans les années 1920 et bien
d'autres encore il y a eu toujours déjà
en avance mais en France comme ailleurs
il faut un système global la Finlande
pourquoi elle l'a fait parce que elle a
fait table rase du système ancien ça va
pas
la même chose une des réformes majeures
c'est décentralisée
et on est on est un petit pays comparé
au grand pays du monde on est un petit
pays bien sûr que c'est possible merci
beaucoup Jacques Attali comme d'habitude
je vous renvoie vous voyez bien qu'il y
a encore beaucoup de choses à piocher à
apprendre dans cette histoire et à venir
de l'éducation au pluriel et vous allez
voir ces passionnants c'est aux éditions
Flam